i've been taking lessons from my chum 21
savage
when i'm done with you you're gonna need
more than just thoughts and prayers
rhyme battling an american a spitting
situation i'm responsible for starting
it this poem and your nation so smile
while i beguile and outshine this
commoner it's just like eight mile or
12.9 kilometers this format excites me
that will insult you nicely it's
unsightly to fight so i'll rhyme quite
politely i'll take over the rap game
expediently colonize and if i hurt your
feelings immediately apologize shut the
cuck up don't tread on me try rap once
you figure out dentistry you're a
candy-ass hack your line's unimpressive
i go hard on the track you go passive
aggressive i'm a steak knife you're a
silver spoon you to doctor who we put a
man on the moon have you seen your queen
she's like fossilized [ __ ] imma say what
i mean suck my circumcised
time to put your lights out burn you
like it's 1812 and you're the bloody
white house your country is divided
that's a fraction nation give smallpox
to the natives but scared of vaccination
what we call the loo you call the john
we love to queue you love q anon i
stepped it up a gear like i'm shifting
into second you use automatics almost at
your weapons that's how we beat the
nazis blasted them like firm and if we
hadn't saved your asses then you'd all
be speaking german you think you're cool
like james bond you're more like austin
powers and you pissed away your empire
like a goddamn golden shower said [ __ ]
you to eu shut down your borders gave up
your platform nine and three quarters we
slipped throats of red coats and made
you all flee shout out boston harbor
cause i just spilled the cheese you say
potato we say potato we have a prime
minister you have a dictator a
democratic nation torn apart by
hostility your presidential ballot
spends two types of
penelope tiny ass island that's past its
prime we made a bigger impact in half
the time for the shittiest weather you
are the hub you got cold drafts
everywhere except in your pub you call
us alcoholics it's the mildest devices
while your drug of choice is an opioid
crisis you eat like slobs put on pounds
like our money we gave you the office
then you made it not funny you invaded
india 30 million died your driving's
like your history on the wrong side even
your pristine prince andrew touched
children at least with epstein we had
the courtesy to kill him sorry to
interrupt but i got something to say if
countries were getting ranked canada
would get an a i'm like maple syrup
you'll tap out when i flow we got tar
sand money now that's true dough pardon
my french but what the heck try to step
to me with a boot on your neck you're a
hockey loving hoser that's poutine at
bloodley get lost [ __ ] go back to your
country what did you say
can it be true we're not so different
you hate foreigners too
[Music]
you